[Music]
[Music]
greetings you bad [ __ ] uncle
Joey Monday the 14th of November you
halfway [ __ ] done 10 days away from
Thanksgiving you still sitting there
what am I gonna do
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
great weekend in Boston I want to thank
everybody who came out to the Wilbur
teeth I wanna thank everybody who came
out to Foxwoods I mean they were [ __ ]
great shows you guys are great thank you
very much [ __ ] too much Friday I'm in
the Houston Texas area we're doing to
come and take it tour but anyway who
gives a [ __ ] about that right now
I'm talking about us how you guys but
today we got [ __ ] hardcore from the
Russians and I'm ready to go before you
asked me another [ __ ] stupid McGregor
question let me ask you [ __ ] up
okay number one I was on stage I didn't
watch the fight though last night
congratulation to Conor McGregor but for
number two for you [ __ ] morons how
much did you make did you bet the fly
that you have any [ __ ] balls to the
right thing so unless you bet to fight
and whatever don't [ __ ] hit me up if
you just watch it with your little
[ __ ] friends you [ __ ] we vote me
Greg I don't want to hear from you dawg
when you want some money show me that
[ __ ] take it will talk [ __ ]
chicken okay well I have sloughing Diaz
against ruptor McGregor I showed you the
ticket that I not with big [ __ ] money
so don't talk to me about your [ __ ]
stories all right if you didn't win no
money go [ __ ] yourself
if you just watched it with your little
gay friends that don't mean victim is
none to you put the [ __ ] paper down
that's the commitment I was never a fan
of nobody
I'm a fan whoever covers the [ __ ]
spread so remember that from the jump
you dumb [ __ ] anyway that's the
Spoken Reasons
oh it's a beautiful day to be alive we
have a podcast some 8 o'clock tonight
we got a podcast Wednesday you know
Houston on Friday
that's [ __ ] Wednesday wet The Improv
oh [ __ ] the night before Thanksgiving
stars bazookas grenades we foot everyone
from the Chinese guy we're not [ __ ]
around but that's it that's that brother
I'm just trying to put two and two
together and resting I got a meeting at
- I gotta go to jujitsu and get my
[ __ ] fat down and beside that that's
it I'm just like you I'm just trying to
put [ __ ] something together that's it
we all put our pants on one leg at a
[ __ ] time man that's why I don't give
a [ __ ] about anyway even Jesus put his
little pants on well he had no pants he
had a [ __ ] Claude so you got me there
[ __ ] I'm not impressed I don't
give a [ __ ] I gotta get up just by
giving more him banging out with the
rest of these [ __ ] and that's
exactly what I've been doing since I was
[ __ ] baked 14 I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] about football I don't
have a football gonna give a [ __ ] about
how we're gonna make some [ __ ] paper
today and I'm gonna feed my [ __ ]
family and 20 years ago I was gonna
stuff my nose with [ __ ] blow so
there's always a [ __ ] purpose to go
out there and make it down okay so cut
the [ __ ]
Christmas is six weeks away you need to
do a thousand [ __ ] things and you
want to sit there and did you watch the
game I don't give a [ __ ] anyway I'm
feeling good
rested it's gonna be a good week or you
Hillary people knock it off it's over
okay you didn't know you didn't [ __ ]
know you [ __ ] them so not at all the
Trump people I'm proud for you
everybody's happy I could not vote I got
the felonies but all I want you guys
know is just relax who gives a [ __ ] your
life's gonna be the same wherever the
[ __ ] it is and it's been the same I've
heard a thousand I've heard some of the
dumbest remarks of all time for this
election and the people who made them
you know what man
pack up and leave you don't even belong
in America you don't even belong in
America you've become something else
this different type of [ __ ] liberal
Gentile or something in America and
America we go for the best we kick ass
we got up early one morning same thing
swing dick we just keep going with
rookie sex this no he's this all he's
that who gives a [ __ ] and Hillary's a
[ __ ] criminal dawg
so who gives a [ __ ] okay get your life
together
grab your balls write your goals and go
out there but get what [ __ ] belongs
don't you I don't know it belongs to you
only you know what belongs to you so get
your [ __ ] together right that's it and
that's that if I told you I'm [ __ ]
stoned Toledo's well now you know I
gotta take two well
go over and saw some sidekicks for Jesus
maybe I'm just gonna [ __ ] feel I get
some Sun that I hear we just wanna get
some Sun you just want to say [ __ ]
jump some rope what do you think about
that [ __ ] it's been a while
anyway tonight 8 o'clock the Church of
what's happened now be there or be
[ __ ] sweat and that's it and that's
that have a great day uncle Joey loves
you remember doesn't matter you still
got to get up and do your [ __ ] thing
you still gotta get up every day and
impose your [ __ ] will all this other
[ __ ] is background music to get you
unfocused trust me I'm 53 I lost so many
[ __ ] years because I wasn't focused
because of this [ __ ] they throw I hear
in the deck don't worry about nothing
don't the vacation I don't give a [ __ ]
just take care of it the right car
suckers I'm [ __ ] stoned stay black
I'll see you in a few hours